(audience cheers)
- I just learned this.
I love this about you.
Your middle name is Jazz.
- Yeah.
- Is one of your parents huge into jazz?
- I literally just texted
my dad saying, "Why Jazz?"
And he replied, "Me like Daisy Jazz."
- Me Like Daisy Jazz.
- That's it.
- Caveman.
- Yeah.
- Me like Daisy Jazz.
- Texting is so caveman.
- I know, but it's such a rad middle name.
I've never heard that.
- Yeah, my middle sister is Kika-Rose.
So he chose the Kika,
my mom chose the Rose.
And then my eldest is Poppy Sophia.
- Oh, all flowers in there.
- Yeah.
- I like it. I'm obsessed
with flowers.
- Also, I'm shook
from that performance.
- Oh, you're so...
(audience applauds)
Thank you.
(Daisy claps)
(audience cheers)
Do you...?
I mean, I bet you do.
The only way that's relatable is
I never sing something
generally the same twice.
Especially when it comes to blues music.
Are you like that in like acting like
when you do different scenes constantly,
are they always slightly different?
- Yes, I think in the world of,
but also I think now
having produced two films.
But my film, which is a different film
to the one I'm here to talk
about. But it's called "Magpie."
It's very helpful in the edit too,
to have slightly different things.
Because sometimes you're like, "Oh, yeah.
Maybe that works a little better
in the context of film."
- In how it edits in.
Yeah, same thing with singing, yeah.
Do you love producing? 'Cause yeah,
now you're producing as well.
- Yeah, my first love is acting.
But it's nice to be like,
"Let's get this done."
- Let's get it in, get in there.
Well 'cause not everybody...
I don't like producing even in music.
I like doing what I do and then
everybody else will produce.
But I have a lot of music friends that...
Musicians who do everything,
and they're really gifted at that.
That's not a talent that everybody has.
- I mean, I don't do everything.
- No, I just mean as an actor though,
and also producing, maybe
directing, like a people person.
There are certain people that
really have that capability.
- I mean, there are other people
who are so much better
at all of the stuff.
But with the film I made with my husband,
he called me the engine.
'Cause I was like, "We are gonna do this
and this is how we're gonna do it."
- Thomas, the little engine.
- Oh, Thomas.
- Thomas, the little engine that could.
I like it, I like it.
I have kids.
- Amazing.
- Wait, are you good
at keeping resolutions?
We're still early in the year.
Are you good at making
them and keeping them?
I'm not.
- Right.
- Yeah, I don't even know why I make 'em.
I'm never gonna learn Spanish fully.
It's just never gonna happen.
(audience laughs)
Never gonna happen.
I just need to accept it.
- Mm.
- I can get by.
- That's good though.
- Is it? It's settling.
(Daisy laughs)
It's a little bit of
settling, but I think...
Is it a tourist thing? I don't know.
I'm fine with average.
- I mean, I've been learning
French for four years.
- Oh, me too. That's another one.
But that Duolingo owl is
so disappointed in me.
(Daisy laughs)
Yeah.
- The Duolingo is thrilled.
- The app changes.
It changes. That owl used to smile at me.
And now, I go to the app, he's very angry.
- Duo is very pleased with me,
'cause I'm not joking, I'm on day 1,400.
But I'm like, "Yeah, but
I can't speak French."
(audience laughs)
I should be fluent.
- You are that committed.
- I am.
- I can't even get through
the seven day streak.
(Kelly laughs and claps)
Literally I get to day six
and there's something
self sabotaging about me
that's just like, "I'm skipping a day."
I'm like, "I don't have to do it."
I'm proud of you right now.
Wow.
- Thank you.
- You probably know enough
to get by with French.
- Yeah.
- Okay.
- And it's the confidence thing, right?
- Yeah, maybe that's what I'm lacking.
You travel so much, you do films.
Are you adventurous when you travel?
- You I've become way less adventurous.
- I think that's age.
- Yeah.
- So I used to be more
adventurous in my twenties.
Now I'm like, "I might break something."
- Yeah, I mean, I do films
that are quite adventurous.
I recently played the first
woman to swim the Channel.
So I was in the Black Sea
for nine days swimming
and the safety boat would
leave, and then I'm there.
- Alone.
And after that I didn't
swim again, and then...
- That's terrifying to me.
That's actually one of those
things that they say...
Your worst fear is just getting left
and just treading water in the ocean.
- And I was like, well,
I knew what was in there
because it was a contained sea.
So I knew the were sharks.
- Oh, then I'd of been fine.
- But my thing is current
and the scary stuff.
But yeah, I've become...
Me and my husband went on a
walk on some famous cliffs.
in Ireland.
- Beautiful.
- I couldn't do it.
- What?
- I was like, (gags).
Literally, (gags).
(Kelly laughs)
So scared.
- Oh my god, it does get very windy too.
- It does.
- Yeah, I love that though.
It feels fresh and like a
brand new day. I like it.
Anyway, are you always
affected by heights though?
Are you one of those actors that says
I can do heights and then you get to it
and then you-
- Yeah.
- You are, okay?
- All of you are the same.
- I'm like the CV liar.
I just did a film where
I play a window cleaner.
And they said...
Oh yeah, this was actually something else
I was supposed to do on a mountain
that I ended up not doing.
So I was learning with an amazing guy.
- You are pretty great.
- That was... Yeah, I was fine.
(audience applauds)
- Hurt my knees.
It hurt my knees watching.
- I was asked if I liked
heights to do this film
and I was like, "Love heights."
And they were like, "Great.
We are gonna put you on the side
of a building, yada, yada, yada."
I was like, "Fantastic."
Went home and was like, "Oh
my god, what have I done?"
And then a few weeks later,
we were closer to the film
and they were like, "We're so sorry.
We can't actually put you up.
There's insurance problems."
I was like, "Guys, I was so
looking forward to that."
- The best acting you've
done in the whole film.
Like, "Oh my god, so sad."
I would never do that
for any amount of money.
I don't mind heights,
but like, why die when
your life is all right?
Why give it the the
chance, you know? Anyway.
(audience applauds)
- Her new movie, " Sometimes
I think About Dying."
It's in theaters now,
very uplifting title.
Explain the movie.
- The film is not sad.
I'm just gonna say that.
The film follows a woman
called Fran, who I play,
who has some trouble socially,
but has a very original life.
So has these sort of imaginings of death.
Not in a morbid way, just in a,
that's just what she thinks about.
And a new guy as played
by Dave, joins the office,
and she is interested in him.
And it's sort of her journey
of overcoming the difficulty
she has in connecting with people.
- Yeah, absolutely.
I think a lot of people relate to that.
Maybe not think about dying
all the time, but, yeah.
That's a little intense.
But there's a scene with actual
real bugs crawling on you.
How'd that go over?
- I thought I didn't mind bugs.
I have one where the ants are crawling
on my hand, that was fine.
And there's one where I
am doing a death Tableau
and I had some bugs in my
hand, but I couldn't move.
And I was literally like, "Oh, my god."
I'm just gagging all the time.
Over the cliff, lying down.
- Everything.
- And that was horrid.
But it's also 'cause you can't move.
When you're interacting
with something, it's fine.
- Yeah, but then you feel helpless.
- Helpless.
- Yeah.
I don't like that.
- No.
- So there's not a lot of dialogue.
Do you enjoy that though?
'Cause that's kind of cool as an actor,
just physically in a
different way being able
to interact in a scene.
- Yeah, I feel like I've never done
the most talky character, to be honest.
But this is my least talky.
There was the least talking.
But there was voiceover
the whole way through
and I was like, "Why don't I treat this
like stage directions instead?"
So in my head I was very busy.
I learned all the dialogue
so it was like running all the time.
So I felt like I was
speaking, but I wasn't.
But yeah, I play a quiet person.
- Yeah, you did well with the accent.
- Thank you.
(audience laughs)
- You sound amazing.
- Thank you so much.
- But you also love to sing
and I hear that you love karaoke, right?
- Yeah.
- What's your go-to?
- Toni Braxton, "Unbreak My Heart."
- Oh, my god.
(audience applauds and cheers)
You came out with one of the
greatest singers, Toni Braxton,
and then you said the hardest
song, "Unbreak My Heart."
- I mean, I haven't done
that in a long time,
but there's a gay bar in Soho.
I mean, they used to have
karaoke every Tuesday.
And I remember thinking,
"I've never felt like
this before in my life."
I did a song, I was like,
"Everyone's so nice."
(Kelly laughs)
- I'm incredible?
- I'm amazing, we're all amazing.
- Everyone's drunk.
- Exactly, everyone's
like, "What's going on?"
- I'm just saying "Unbreak
My Heart" is a song
that most people should not attempt.
That's incredible. You
must be an alto, I'm not.
- I am an alto, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah,
I mean, I still shouldn't attempt it.
- No.
- It was just that one time.
- First of all, at karaoke,
you should attempt everything.
So I just have to ask,
'cause everybody's a
huge fan of Star Wars,
do you have any kind of tease?
I know you can't say too much, but...
- It is happening.
(Kelly laughs)
(audience cheers)
- Woo!
- Solid news.
- I know the general story.
Which is very cool.
- [Kelly] It's been a minute though
since you've done something.
It's been like, how
long since the last...?
- Well, what's crazy is time passing.
It was 11 years ago when I got cast.
- That's right.
- I was a baby.
- You're still a baby, says your skin.
You're welcome, from genetics.
(audience laughs)
- Yeah, so it's been quite a few years
since I've been part of that world.
- Kind of cool to jump back in the role
that many years later, right?
- Yeah, and also strange
'cause I was the baby
and now I'm like, "Oh,
I'm gonna go in as like,
I got married and done other stuff."
And I feel more like a grownup now.
So I'm looking forward to it.
- A real woman, yeah.
I like it. I'm excited.
You have so many projects and you said,
the one I wanna mention real quick,
you said... Is it "Magpie?"
- "Magpie," yes.
- That you're working on.
And that's the one you
did with your husband?
- Yes, that is premiering at
South by Southwest in March.
- Oh, awesome. Very cool.
All the things in the air.
You're floating all the things.
Let's take another break, everybody.
Daisy's movie, "Sometimes
I Think About Dying"
it's just a fun title to
say, it's in theaters now.
Be sure to check it out.